tenemos aquí una ecuación que nos dice
que menos 2 por esta expresión de aquí
de cuadrada más 6 menos 3 esta
multiplicación es igual a d porque al
cubo más 12 porque al cuadrado más cf
por ye y lo que me gustaría que hicieras
es que le pusieras pausa el vídeo e
intentes por tu cuenta
averiguar cuáles son estos coeficientes
de aquí cuánto vale sé cuánto vale de y
cuánto vale
efe bueno vamos a resolverlo paso por
paso al principio esto puede parecer muy
oscuro cómo le vamos a hacer para
averiguar cuánto valen estos
coeficientes y un muy buen primer paso
sería simplificar este lado de aquí o
sea distribuir el menos 2 en este
polinomio de aquí y lo que nos quede
tiene que ser igual a lo que tenemos por
aquí y de esa forma tal vez podemos
asociar algunos coeficientes entonces
pues vamos a distribuir lo que tenemos
los dos sí y lo vamos a multiplicar
porque cuadrada y menos 2 porque al
cuadrado es menos 2 y al cubo nunca
porque ya a la 1 porque a la 2 y la 3
muy bien ahora vamos a multiplicar menos
2 por c y eso es igual a menos 26
- 2 c o sea que nos queda menos 2 c de
cuadrada y ahora vamos a multiplicar
menos 2 por y aquí estamos restando 3
podríamos decir que tenemos menos 3 y
entonces menos 2 por menos 3 es más 6
pero pues también tenemos estaré por
aquí
ok
ya simplificamos el lado izquierdo de
esta ecuación y sabemos que es igual al
lado derecho de la ecuación pero vamos a
escribirlo con distintos colores a ver
si te salta a la vista cuánto tienen que
valer estos coeficientes del lado
izquierdo escribí el término de grado 3
de color azul entonces de este lado
también vamos a escribir el término de
grado 3 de color azul
ok b porque a la 3 y luego tenemos aquí
que el término de grado 2 está de color
rosa así es que vamos a poner el término
de grado 2 también de color rosa 12
porque a la 2 y finalmente escribimos el
término de grado 1 en color verde por lo
que vamos a escribir el término de grado
1 también de color verde
por qué
y ya que lo tenemos así podemos ver
claramente qué términos están asociados
con qué términos por ejemplo aquí
tenemos el término de grado 3 de este
lado y sabemos que tiene que ser igual
al término de grado 3 de este otro lado
y entonces sabemos que b tiene que ser
igual a menos 2 que íbamos a escribirlo
por aquí b tiene que ser igual a menos 2
también sabemos que el término de
segundo grado de aquí está asociado con
este otro término de segundo grado y eso
nos dice que 12 tiene que ser igual a
menos 2 c menos 2
se tiene que ser igual a 12 y para
encontrarse lo único que necesitamos es
dividir entre menos dos de los dos lados
y nos queda que se es igual 12 entre
menos 2 es menos 6
y eso tiene mucho sentido porque por
aquí si tenemos menos 2 c y c es menos 6
entonces estamos restando 2 x menos 6 o
sea que estamos restando menos 12 y eso
pues es igual a sumar 12 y entonces si
tenemos exactamente el mismo coeficiente
para los dos términos de grado 2 me
imagino que ya sabes qué es lo que va a
pasar a continuación por aquí tenemos un
6 como el término de primer grado y por
acá tenemos un f y como el término del
primer grado está efe este coeficiente
tiene que ser igual a éste otro
coeficiente de aquí a este 6 creo yo
entonces
efe tiene que ser igual a 6
ya terminamos ahora la clave para
resolver esto es asociar los
coeficientes de términos con el mismo
grado y no me quiero meter en cosas muy
complejas pero una forma de verlo es
pensar ok la única forma que tengo de
obtener este término de grado 3 de este
lado es a través del término de grado 3
entonces me fijo en los coeficientes y
tienen que ser iguales